No. Not the American.
No. I'm begging you... No! Don't!
welcome back everyone it's Charlie big
surprise we got an early stranger thing
season 4 trailer so we'll break it down
there a couple big Easter eggs in this
and we know a little bit about what's
happening with the season 4 storyline I
will be doing stranger things season 4
videos just like I did for season 3 and
season 2 so if you're new to my channel
be sure to subscribe to get everything
one of the reasons why they're dropping
this so early is because they need to
start production on season 4 because the
kids are aging up so quickly within
another year or two they're gonna look
like the teenagers so this does seem
like it's going to be one of the final
seasons of the show they might do season
5 but they just signed a new first look
deal at Netflix with the duffer brothers
to develop other shows so unless they
have a big spin-off of stranger things
planned it sounds like they're planning
on moving away from stranger things
after they're done with season 4 but as
you see this picture of Hawkins slowly
turning into the upside down and you see
the camera pan out a little bit with
that season 4 logo flash up you see a
clock counting down to midnight with the
tones starting to chime that's a
reference to the Doomsday Clock which is
all about countdown to total
annihilation there was a turn of the guy
used a lot during the Cold War Between
the Soviet Union in the USA obviously in
the context of stranger things is all
about the final battle between Eleven in the
mind flayer will their battle tear apart
both dimensions mutually-assured
telekinetic psychic destruction but the
trademark upside down organic material
growing over everything the blue
coloration the tagline implied that the
final battle will take place inside the
upside down even though we've traveled
there a couple times in Eleven got trapped
there between season 1 and season 2
aside from will being trapped in there
for the entirety of season 1 none of the
other characters have spent a really
long period inside the upside down
they've only been in there briefly
that's why will has that weird
connection to the mind flayer so even
though he doesn't have special powers
the way that Eleven have special powers even
though technically her powers aren't
working right at the end of the season
I'll address that in a second he does
have sort of this precognition for the
mind flayer coming for them he knows
when it's around or when it's about to
attack and that's really useful when
you're trying to avoid or trying to
fight it but because that scene at the
end the tag line is also a reference to
Russia field trip because I feel like
we're all on the same page that the
American that the Russian guards are
talking about income chaka Russia in the
secret russian base is hopper and he was
captured at the end of the season and
that big explosion when everyone
actually thought that he died because
there was no body but apparently the
reason there was no body is because the
Russians captured him when they were
trying to escape there's a lot of
missing time in between that explosion
when you actually see them walking
around looking for bodies and actually
trying to find people the military has
since been down there to inspect but
there is a lot of unaccounted for time
for those Russians to grab hopper and
get away or at least a couple that
survived the explosion the brand-new
white demagogue in that comes out to eat
this Russian prisoner at the end it's
just more confirmation of that because
how would they get a demo gorgon if they
weren't the same Russians from Hawkins
hey listen
yeah how big did you see that demo
Google was because if you remember the
Russians were secretly trying to open
their own gate there are many places
around the world where the barriers
between dimensions are weak but the only
people in the world that were actually
successfully able to open a portal were
the people in Hawkins because of Elevens
accident because she was so much more
powerful than the other psychics that
were popping up around the world so even
though it seems like the doctor and all
those people during season 1 had this
very special program you had to imagine
that the Soviets had their exact same
group of people that they were testing
trying to create their own version of Eleven
but they weren't as successful that was
the whole reason for the Russians to
come to Hawkins and secretly build a
star court mall so that it could be
cover for them using the Hawkins portal
so if the kids are gonna go fight the
mind flayer on its home turf inside the
upside down there are only a couple of
places they can use to get to the upside
down one that can go back to Hawkins
like they say we're not at Hawkins
anymore technically they do have to come
back to Hawkins to use the portal at the
Hawkins lab or if some of them are going
to travel to Russia that Eleven could try to
open the Russian portal herself they
were unsuccessful when they tried it
themselves but they didn't have eleven
eleven only accidentally opened the
portal for the first time when she was
using her power to try and reach someone
that was all the way across the world in
Russia they were trying to use her to
spy on the Soviets so they actually have
already been to Russia on the TV show
it's just that they haven't used those
flashbacks where eleven is using her
mind to reach out to Russia she might
actually be able to see hopper doing
that same trick too as for eleven losing
her powers at the end of the season
that's just
results of them closing the gate between
dimensions she has sort of this weird
link with the mind flayer in the upside
down so I think that the minute that
they open a new portal to the upside
down her powers will just automatically
turn back on and then when they defeat
the mind flayer inevitably at the end of
the season then her powers might
permanently go away talking about Big
Ideas hero's journey Eleven will have to
sacrifice something in order to defeat
the mind flayer and usually that means
sacrificing your life but I think the
whole idea of the show it's a little
more hopeful it actually wants Eleven to get
the things that she wants for herself
she wants a normal life so what would
she sacrifice she would probably
sacrifice her powers in order to defeat
the mind player so early prediction
they're successful in defeating the mind
player at the end of the season then her
true reward at the end of the season is
getting to live that normal life that
she's always wanted I haven't heard
anything about spin-offs yes they could
drag this out to Season 5 but I don't
know like the kids are just getting so
old look at how much different they look
between season 2 in the two year time
jump that it took to get season 3
episodes when they went on that great
break and they had to sign all those new
deals and pay all this extra money all
the kids got giant pay raises there was
talk of doing seasons three and four
back-to-back to avoid any potential
delays and issues that will require them
to use De aging technology to make the
kids look younger if you saw the it
movie and then in Chapter two they
actually had to do that with some of
those kids they had to de-age kids when
they got to it chapter two because two
years ago by when they started filming
it so they looked way way older than
they did during it chapter one in the
flashbacks were supposed to be to that
time period so there was always
continuity issues so that's why you try
to move really fast on new seasons when
you have child actors pretty safe bet
that they're gonna drop season 4
episodes fourth of July weekend next
year just like they did this year they
really like that summer holiday weekend
in related Netflix news The Witcher
series with Henry Cavill is premiering
later this year they have not given us a
hard premiere date but the rumor is that
it's going to be around Christmas time
in December so even though New York
Comic Con is coming up they haven't said
whether or not they're gonna drop a new
trailer for that but I will be doing
which er Netflix videos so leave all
your requests in the comments below
while you wait for everything click here
for The Witcher Netflix trailer and
click here for the brand-new Rick and Morty
season 4 teaser trailer thank you so
much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight!